[Musik]
gemeinsam für ein sicheres österreich
das ist das motto der jahrelang in
kooperation zwischen den öbb und dem
verteidigungsministerium den
österreichischen bundesheer sowie die
österreichischen bundesbahnen dafür
sorgen dass zielgerichtet die passagiere
an ihren ort aufkommen so schützen wir
österreich und sorgen für die
österreicherinnen und österreicher wir
schauen uns heute das begeben der lok an
auf der einen seite mit einem
fallschirmspringer von unserer elite
einheit vom jagd kommando und auf der
anderen seite von einem unserer soldaten
von einem pieks jäger wir freuen uns
sehr jetzt bereits zum dritten mal in
folge eine wunderschöne bundesheer lok
auf schiene zu bringen
ein sehr sehr schönes design wir sind
sehr stolz darauf mit zwei wunderbar
schönen sujets auf den beiden seiten der
taurus lok ein besonderes highlight
werden die mini lag sein die wir dann in
unserem webshop in ungefähr sechs
monaten zur verfügung haben werden und
die für unsere eisenbahnliebhaber dann
ein besonderes highlight darstellen
werden das österreichische bundesheer
ist vielfältig es hat aber mit den öbb
eines gemeinsam sicherheit durch
zuverlässigkeit wir schützen österreich
und das machen wir gemeinsam mit unserer
bundeswehr
[Musik]